foreign
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity the left as you know has
repeatedly pushed the envelope to
continue every day in their never-ending
culture War
Well author Victor Davis Hanson has
written a fantastic new op-ed where he
called that war a quote full-fledged
cultural revolution against traditional
America his closing sentence in the
editorial is our first question tonight
why are our government corporations and
popular culture colluding in mass
suicide to the Delight of our enemies
like communist China
Victor Davis Hansen joins us now with
more Victor why are those institutions
colluding in America's what they why do
they want American suicide
I don't know exactly but I think they
feel that if they're correct
ideologically then they get a pass on
every type of behavior and that behavior
leads to sort of the destruction of
Institutions and that's not necessarily
a bad thing because they feel America
was flawed in its origin so you take art
here in California where we're facing 32
billion dollars in debt Pete why would a
council or Commission on reparations say
that we're going to get 800 billion
dollars
why not a trillion but to African
Americans when we were a free state
that's eight Generations ago and then
when confronted with those realities the
commission says well we're willing to
take it on installment or I was just
reading you know we we're looking at the
tragic death on the subway and I thought
wow this guy looks like he's a career
criminal that was killed I thought maybe
he had a rest of five seven how does
somebody in the criminal justice system
have a an arrest record of 40 arrests
including violent assault lewd conduct
and then his uncle weighed in and I
thought wow he's weighing in in support
of his deceased nephew maybe he has a
criminal record he's been arrested 70
times what kind of Criminal Justice
System I guess ideologically just excuse
felony Behavior 70 times or we look at
the border I thought wow it might be
porous we might under the Biden
Administration have a hundred thousand
or two hundred thousand illegal entries
but
they just blew it up it doesn't exist we
can't even imagine six and a half
million illegal entries and we look at
the Los Angeles Dodgers you know Greater
Los Angeles has probably got the largest
city in North America of people of
Mexican American or Central American or
Hispanic heritage the majority are
Catholic most are still observant
baseball along with soccer is that the
national Pastime and the
Spanish-speaking communities here and
elsewhere why would the Los Angeles
Dodgers who can depends on this
constituency at a time when people are
you know audiences for professional
sports are in Decline why would they
invite the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence when their stock and Craig is
performance art blasphemy simulated sex
pornographic uh attacks on the Trinity
the Catholic faith what what makes them
do that is that they're hiring people
out of MBA programs that are woke or
they don't care but the general theme in
all of these incidents is that certain
people feel they can take it to the old
ultimate level to insult traditional
America and there's no consequences
whether Target or Disney or Bud Light
and you were talking about the FBI Pete
but I thought maybe an FBI director
might FIB once but how did Andrew McCabe
lie four times three times under oh or
James
Clapper lied about the NSA under oath
the head of the NSA and he just simply
laughed it off as well it's at least on
truthful answer or John Brennan lied
twice under oath CIA director and James
Comey I thought when he's in there and
Devin Nunez and people are interviewing
he might claim Amnesia 10 or 20 times
but 245 time so what I'm getting at is
there's an arrogance that people feel
that they can say or do whatever they
want because ideologically they feel
they're protected or exempt and even if
that destroys these institutions we've
destroyed the FBI the CIA the IRS
Corporate America and the border and I
think traditional economical racial
relations it just keeps going as if it's
a Jacobin or some type of updated French
Revolution and I don't think we're we in
traditional America understand what's
going on our enemies do that's why I
think they're delighted about it
evil that's why you've mentioned
communist China That's why of course
they export Tick Tock to fill our our
kids Minds with nonsense and evil things
but won't allow their own kids in China
to see those very same things and
Fentanyl I mean you you take your pick
these corporations clearly they know
these issues don't enhance their bottom
line tucking it in at Target isn't going
to bring in a new customer base they're
signaling the government is protecting
one political power the cultural rocked
I think because Andrew Breitbart once
said you know politics is Downstream of
culture my pastor said culture's
Downstream of religion I mean what you
believe in what you have faith in
informs the culture you have and
ultimately the politics that unfold
where between culture and religion or
faith because this feels like a
religious belief amongst those on the
left very different form of religious
belief where does that come from and how
do we how do we confront it
well I think if you're an agnostic or an
atheist you're going to invent your own
Gods and that's sort of a Trope of
philosophy and they've invented these
woke gods for some it's Mother Earth or
a green deity for some it's
redistribution or awoke goddess and they
feel that they have all the fervent
belief of True Believer and they're
intolerant in a way that you know a
fundamentalist can be and if you don't
believe in Transcendence and they don't
then you have these material gods and
and they're political and they're not
they're not forgiving and so what they
do is if you're a True Believer in the
left they feel that certain privileges
accrue to them they're exempt from the
full force of the law they're able to go
into a cake person and say you're going
to bake this cake no matter if it's
against your religion but that wouldn't
be occur to us you can't do that back to
us or if you're you know Devin Mr
Mulvaney
uh he wasn't really pushing Bud Light I
don't think he ever had a Bud Light in
his life the point was he was trying to
show transgenderism and push it down the
throats of Americans just like female
sports we have 50 years of feminists
trying to get equity for women and all
of a sudden we have biological males
that are cleaning up and destroying
records of women and and having an
unfair advantage and they've done more
damage to female Equity than a hundred
years of chauvinist male pigs in sports
and no one says a word because
ideologically that's considered an
exempt group but everybody knows that if
you're a if you're a male and you
transition to female you're going to
have a biological Advantage but on the
other hand they tell us no no that
you're you're purely female but then we
know the professional American says yeah
but men men that transition to women
don't clean up uh I mean women that
translation transition to men don't
clean up and then Sports there's a
difference there's a biological
difference so it's just falls on deaf
ears so I think we're in America look at
all of these things and we think this is
not the old politics this is not the end
part of the out party the left the right
this is something new this is beyond the
60s cultural revolution this is kind of
like maoism where it's totality they
want to go into every aspect of our life
private life economic political social
cultural and change it and ideological
and they're going to reward people who
follow that and they're going to punish
people that say not this pig I'm not
going to do it and that's what we see if
you're always this evening Mike
you're going to be punished if you're if
you're a secular Zealot and that is your
religion it's a zero-sum game which
means the ends justify the means which
means you destroy corporations that give
people jobs you destroy institutions
that used to give Equal justice in
service of that religious celetary and
where the Carnage leads nobody knows
nobody clarifies it better than you
Victor Davis Hanson thank you for your
time we appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else